the next one I'm going to cheat a little
bit remember I said to you six formulas
you get given to four of them you must
actually know one two three the fourth
one the second she gets given to you so
you don't need to memorize that the the
fourth one is actually two in one so
we'll be able to do this together the
kite and Aramis okay now cards and rumba
sirs are kind of um I just don't need
this
they kind of like cousins if you want a
picture of clay in fact let's all draw a
client now if you picture a client like
so okay yeah you could help the two a
word for kites is a diamond okay what
makes it kind of like me to tell you
guys is that you've got a pair of
adjacent sides equal up there and you've
got another pair of adjacent sides that
are equal down there okay now it's very
easy to turn a kite into a rhombus right
instead of just having these two equal
and these two equal right if you make
these pairs equal to each other as well
you've turned your client into rhombus
now don't draw it you don't need to it's
gonna be exactly the same just move down
a little bit okay
I'm gonna show you the same kind of
trick we played with the triangle will
work here okay just like I drew a big
box around my triangle I want to draw a
big box around my clients okay but
before we do that you just need to know
one more thing
kites enormous is really cool when you
draw their diagonals and if you draw an
actual kite like if you have done your
constructions and measured out so it's
actually accurate if you draw both
diagonals you will find importantly that
the diagonals are perpendicular to each
other
okay now that fact doesn't seem innocent
nice but any bit random but why is it
important to us well watch what happens
when I draw my box whenever my rectangle
around my kites or my rhombus okay
I'm using ruler so you can see we're
going to get something like this okay
now do you remember what happened before
when we drew around the triangle I
created a whole bunch of extra triangles
that were exactly the same size as the
triangles are standard right
and can you see it again can you see it
again look let's call this one triangle
one in the top left right just on the
other side there's another triangle
exactly the same science if you go what'
go clockwise so if you call this one
triangle - there's another triangle
soother keep your going around there's a
three there's another three and lastly
you can say okay so what I've done again
is I've made this big box around here
which is exactly twice the size of what
I want okay now because yes doing this
because they're diagonals there's
they're like base on a kite or rhombus
and it's like which way is the height
like is this behind at that point
instead of calling the base in height we
tend to call the diagonals x and y right
so if you know the days if you can
measure them out again what's the area
of this rectangle this beat rectangle I
just made yeah okay wait hold up the
rectangle is x times y right but what I
want of course is the kind inside up
which is half the size okay
so therefore just like with the triangle
because it's the same argument you're
going to get a half of your big
rectangle which in this case is not be
ages XY okay so what's a little
different but it's not really so even
though I said you know oh you've got
four formulas to actually know and be
able to recall two of them literally
the same and the other two are so
similar okay no I'm going to do the
trapezium next because you see how we
started with a rectangle and we then
just kind of build from there okay so
let's write the a trapezium okay and
what I'd like you to do is draw a
trapezium with me but this is gonna be
an amazing color there's gonna be a bit
trickier okay so I'm gonna draw our
trapezium kind of like this yes but for
our intents and purposes no it's kind of
one of those are you know how like us
they drive on the right so like just
because everyone else tries on the left
and right on the right you know it's
almost the same with the way trapezium
and trapezoid so in the u.s. it means
something different in North America it
means something different but everywhere
else in the world we use Celsius we use
metric and you can but I'm afraid are
you okay now um we need some labels just
like we had to be here right we need
some labels on this thing so the first
two things I'm going to do it just like
before I'm gonna have a perpendicular
height I'm gonna call it that I've kind
of got a base here yeah so I'm gonna
call this fact down the bottom B and
I've gotten to the side that is
different it's parallel and it's kind of
like B so I'm going to call it angry
okay so I've got two parallel sides and
beep I'm interested in those and then
I've got a perpendicular height now
unfortunately or interestingly these
guys are a little harder to deal with
there are lots of ways to get our
formula for the area of this thing you
can slice it up or add things around it
just like we have before my favorite way
requires a bit of help so if instead of
if you think about this trapezium this
one that I've destroyed okay let me just
stop just name let me put those same
labels moment that I had before okay and
I don't want to mess up this so I'm
gonna put my height out here on the
outside just just think it's
perpendicular
okay now what I want to do is I want to
add or subtract to it something that
will get it similar to one of these
shapes I already know okay now I could
try for the rectangle okay but what are
these lots and lots of right angles
everywhere and I kind of don't have any
right angles here right like all these
funny little angles here they're all
really different okay that's kind of
pain so what other kind of shape could I
use remember rectangles out the trial is
just based on the rectangle and so is
the kind of rhombus the kind of one was
just I had a big rectangle ran it so
what's my last option
she's the parallelogram is left okay now
there are all ways of doing it but I
think this is kind of the neatest layer
so if you just take a lemon up so this
is the same trapezium
but now I've got two of them okay now
tell me what shape that is can you tell
me what shape that is that's a
parallelogram right now hold on hold on
what do we need to know to work out the
area of a parallelogram number one you
need this perpendicular height do I have
that I do right it's what I call H
before what's the other thing I need I
need this length okay hold on
what is that length on this
parallelogram yeah do you see cuz I took
this is just this trapezium upside down
right so here's a and you'd be right
so if I want the whole length from here
all the way to here it's a and B
together do you agree
okay so now tell me what's the area of
the parallelogram just the parallelogram
very good it's uh he's my area right
it's the perpendicular height inch and
it's also the width of the whole base
right which we just described as a plus
P but hold on I don't what actually the
whole pie Lily Graham I only want half
of it so just to make it a tiny bit
neater we tend to write it with the H
and the half sort of spun together in
the middle okay so sorry Epis time so do
you see what I did this line here was to
say okay I'm an A plus B was the face of
my parallelograms the height was the
height but the trapezium is just half of
that big parallelograms that I made I
only want the original one